Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, a whole bunch
of you requested a video about all my favorite
shows this year.
There is a lot of stuff I watch that I don’t
do videos for but for the most part I do videos
for stuff I like the most.
So there aren’t a lot of things I’m in
love with that you won’t see on my channel
in some shape or form.
So here’s what I’m going to do.
I’ll name my top 10 shows, and for each
of them, I’ll say my favorite episode of
the year.
I’ll have a couple of announcements about
next week’s videos at the end of this.
So let’s do the thing!
Number 10 - Gotham
Amongst the pantheon of new comic book shows
Gotham above all had the highest chance of
sucking.
It didn’t have Batman or any costumes for
that matter.
And one of it’s central characters was a
little kid.
What made me start to enjoy it was how much
it embraced the campy aspects of the Batman
Universe.
And when I say it’s campy, I mean it goes
to that self-aware silly place that the Animated
Series and the Tim Burton films go to.
Visually there’s a lot of Chris Nolan in
there too.
But my eyes are always drawn to the Tim Burton
type scenes when it gets a little crazier.
Like this scene with Edward Nygma and this
file clerk that he’d like to solve some
bedroom riddles with.
Forget the sexual comedy.
Just look at how they frame this shot and
the set design.
Moments like this are really what I like best
about Gotham.
If you wanted to explain Gotham to your friend.
Don’t say it’s Batman without Batman.
That’s probably the worst way to get someone
excited about it.
Tell them it’s Gotham Central.
It’s a police procedural set around Detective
Gordon and the Gotham City PD.
I know, the big question is why didn’t they
just call it Gotham Central.
The comic book was super popular and had great
stories.
Answer, probably because of rights issues.
I do think a stricter adaptation of Gotham
Central would have been a better show, but
the stories and the characters in the comics
go beyond what Fox is allowed to do legally.
My Favorite Gotham Episode so far is Episode
9 Harvey Dent.
I feel like you could show that episode to
your friends who are fans of Batman and they’d
enjoy it because of Harvey Dent.
And Nicholas D’Agosto did a great job with
the character.
Number 9 - South Park
Ever since the series went from 14 episodes
a season down to 10 I feel like the quality
has gone up.
Because the 6 day production schedule they
have is so above and beyond what normal shows
do, Matt and Trey and the rest of the crew
are almost dead by the end of each run.
Live Action shows take an entire week to shoot
an episode and then another two months of
editing, scoring and post production.
Animated shows can take up to 6 months to
finish.
South Park writes, animates and finishes each
episode in 6 days.
My favorite episode of 2014 is Cock Magic,
although this year there were like 4 episodes
which I thought were better than almost everything
else on tv ever.
But that’s because they were topical, informed
and fucking hilarious.
You don’t need to sell your friends on South
Park, it’s so good it sells itself.
And they make it available to watch everywhere
free.
Number 8 - Agents Of SHIELD
Team Coulson really upped their game.
I was already on board during season 1.
I will freely admit that no matter how ridiculous
or flat this might get, I will still watch
it just because it provides extra context
for the larger workings of the Movies.
But they just debuted brand new IP for the
first time on screen.
And that has me excited for what they can
do with other IP in the future.
The thing that keeps me connected to the show
on an emotional level is Coulson and his relationships
with the other characters.
He is the anchor of this show, with good cause.
I think he’s the most experienced actor
so he does a better job of selling the material,
especially the weirder marvel verse comic
booky stuff.
And in real life he’s like a spirit guide
for all the younger actors who are pushing
themselves to evolve.
Chloe Bennet as Skye for example.
I love what she’s doing this season but
I want more of it.
I think the show does better when it focuses
on a couple things rather than trying to service
10 different characters at once.
The thing to get pumped about is next year,
the back half of this season is going to focus
more on her and the Inhumans.
The movie isn’t coming till after Avengers
3, so now is the time to board the ship.
My favorite SHIELD episode this year is Episode
8 Things We Bury.
It gives us this amazing montage with our
big villain Whitehall and it’s super personal.
You have the Ward brothers going all Cain
and Abel, Whitehall destroying Skye’s Mother
and a great performance from Hayley Atwell
as Peggy Carter.
Number 7 - Walking Dead
The energy from this show mixes so well with
the more pleasant emotions I get from the
other stuff I watch.
Arrow for instance always makes me feel happy
and excited.
But you can’t live on sugar alone.
So Walking Dead is the perfect way to balance
myself.
I always feel excited coming away from episodes.
But usually it’s that type of excitement
you feel after you get in a car crash.
Like you’re having an anxiety attack.
Favorite Episode of this year is the Season
5 Premiere.
Carol wins everything.
drop the mic.
Number 6 - Doctor Who
Far and away my most beloved Science Fiction
series.
I did notice a lot of fallout in the online
fandom between the 50th Anniversary Special
last year and the regular series 8 episodes.
Doctor Who always has this really strong core
fandom that both loves and hates everything
steven moffat does and will tell you exactly
what they think in all CAPS youtube comments.
But for the 50th last year it was like the
whole world zeroed in on The Special.
There’s this big disconnect between what’s
popular in the world and what’s popular
online.
So Doctor Who might not be as big Internationally
as Game of Thrones or Walking Dead, but the
online audience is almost as big because people
are so passionate about it.
Series 8 was very polarizing and that’s
part of the reason I loved it so much.
Doctor Who isn’t afraid to be ridiculous.
It vacillates between really dark serious
stories like Listen and really silly moments
like Cousin It TARDIS.
I’m much more excited by new ideas than
really amazing action or huge twists in the
plot.
So female master and Capaldi’s Doctor made
for a great series.
There are so many other things I could say
about Doctor Who this year but I’ll save
some of it for the bonus videos I’m doing
this week.
The Christmas Special is on December 25th,
for those that don’t know.
I’ll try to get at least a few Doctor Who
videos up before that.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
My favorite Episode this year not including
the Christmas Special, is The Caretaker.
It’s self contained, so you can watch it
without knowing a lot about doctor who.
And it’s very personal.
Number 5 - Legend Of Korra
So sad to see this end.
If you never watched it, they just had the
series finale and set off this same sex relationship
fire
in
the fandom.
Favorite Korra Episode This Year was Korra
Alone.
It’s such a fun deep scan of where Korra
is at Psychologically, it features Katara
and it had the first appearance of Toph in
the new series.
Number 4 - Sherlock
One of the best examples of the genius baby
that’s born when you combine some of the
best actors in the world with the best set
design and the best writing.
If you can’t tell I’m a huge fan of Martin
Freeman and Benedict Cumberbatch.
There is a very good reason why they’re
the biggest actors on the planet right now.
Which is also why it’s so hard for them
to make new sherlock episodes.
Another huge thing to love about the series.
Scarcity.
Because they only do three 90 minute episodes,
there is no filler.
American Television, by contrast, has 20+
weeks of episodes to fill.
So the chances that everything will be amazing
is zero.
When you have 23 episodes a season, not everything
will be awesome.
Sherlock on the other hand doesn’t have
that problem.
My favorite episode this year was Episode
1 Empty Hearse.
It’s just the right balance of drama
and comedy.
If you wanted to get your friend into sherlock,
first show them the sherlock tag on tumblr.
Not the johnlock tag, that’s only for advanced
fans who can handle some of the cringeworthy
fan fiction.
Then show them Series 1 episode 1, Study in
Pink.
I will do a few bonus Sherlock videos in January,
they’ll be filming the 2015 christmas special.
So I’ll include new info as we get pictures
from the set.
Number 3 - The Flash
Of all the new Comic Book Shows, this has
been my favorite.
The characters are the best and the production
crew has created the most emotionally compelling
and interesting universes.
Technically it’s a shared universe with
arrow.
But Flash is very different visually and tonally.
There are a few of the bigger characters I
think still need some work like Iris and Eddie
but I think the back half of the season is
going to spend more time on them.
Harrison Wells is far and away my favorite
Comic Book TV Villain of the year.
He’s a better villain right now than Ra’s
Al Gul, who in the comics is one of the best
Batman villains of all time.
That’s mostly because Wells is inside the
huddle, he’s in every episode and his motivations
are very complex.
He seems very evil but wants to protect the
hero at all costs.
I don’t know if I can pick a single favorite
episode so far.
But Episode 4, The Crossover, which is Episode
8 and Episode 9 are the best.
If you wanted to get your friend into this,
just start them with Episode 1.
Or, if they’re a comic book person, show
them the crossover episode.
Number 2 - Arrow
Because arrow and flash exist in this shared
continuum.
They share creative teams, they share a budget.
So both shows are equal in terms of quality.
Arrow has just had more time to develop it’s
core characters and build out the internal
universe.
So I connect with it emotionally more than
the Flash.
Stephen Amell is an amazing lead both on and
off the camera.
My own experience with the show is a little
meta in that the actors and the network, the
CW network engage with me personally.
Stephen Amell was the first big star to actually
reach out to me on social media to tell me
he liked my youtube channel.
And I’m just a fan of the show.
I’m not some huge media person.
Most actors don’t take the time to engage
with their fans, but because “The Captain”
as we call him, is so connected to the fandom
the other cast members have started to do
so too.
And that’s why shows like Supernatural have
endured for so long.
Jared and Jensen actually interact with and
care about the people watching their show.
My favorite Arrow Episode this year was Episode
9, the mid season finale.
It did the unthinkable.
It had the balls to kill off it’s main character.
Stephen Amell is a big Game of Thrones fan,
so you can think of this as your Arrow Ned
Stark moment.
Number 1 - Game of Thrones
This goes without mentioning but the quality
of the production and the constant one-upsmanship
of each episode make this the best genre show
on tv right now.
When I say genre I just mean, sci fi, fantasy,
horror, you get the idea.
Remember how I said I really like Doctor Who
because it’s so different from other science
fiction.
It’s the same thing with Game of Thrones
and fantasy shows.
George RR Martin is really the person to thank
for that.
He would never have let them adapt it if they
didn’t stick pretty close to his original
narrative.
And yes, they are changing things in the future
but they’re only changing things to make
it linear and make it fit in 10 episodes a
year.
It’s the same situation with South Park,
10 episodes means absolutely no filler.
Not every episode is Oberyn Martell vs The
Mountain, but there aren’t any clip shows.
My favorite episode was number 8.
I’ve rewatched the episodes a couple times
so I can’t remember what my favorite was
earlier this year.
But Episode 8 Viper vs Mountain was one of
the most fun hours of television this year,
period.
If you wanted to get someone into game of
thrones just have them start with season 1
episode 1.
It’s super serialized so starting in Season
5 will just confuse people.
Season 5 is premiering April 5th.
I’ve got a bunch of awesome videos planned
for each of the episodes and some really cool
giveaways.
Seriously, Season 5 will melt your face off.
Honorable Mention - Orphan Black, Constantine,